restait un petit peu avant de parler
sport avant de fermer ce journal ce
mardi le vélodrome national inauguré
vélocité une exposition permanente pensé
par deux historiens du sport
l'exposition se concentre sur le
vélodrome dans l'histoire du cyclisme
des photos des affiches mais aussi des
vélos sont à découvrir je vous propose
d'écouter thomas bauer il est est au
micro de manip ok c'est le commissaire
de l'exposition
ça s'adresse à tout le monde évidemment
on passionné de cyclisme au premier chef
puisque ils vont y voir des images
anciennes
ils vont y retrouver des éléments
mécaniques des éléments raid de
règlement d aspect vestimentaire qui
vont les subs qui vont les anime et on
va dire où les les subjuguer et puis
évidemment c'est une ouverture
culturelle pour olé pour le grand public
qui va découvrir un sport qu'ils ne
soupçonnaient même pas